let me ask you this how long does it
take somebody
to get up and running uh and be
proficient enough in figma
to design an iphone app back to that
like i'm gonna make com a meditation app
or something or sam harris's waking up
meditation app
how long does it take to make an app of
that sophistication
which i would put at medium right it's
not like it's
uber where you have a lot of crazy data
sources and stuff like that but it's
you know it's not a one function app
yeah well as a
as a fan of like that sort of app like
column headspace et cetera like i think
um
i'm just thinking about the interfaces i
mean i think to go from zero to learning
how to
to replicate that in figma yeah you
could do that in a few hours probably
um now if you want to go to the point
where you're a designer
that's able to create a new experience
of that quality
yes well that's that's the only years
right because like that's that's
actually a craft
that's the craft right they're just
duplicating you know if you can do that
in years i'll be very impressed when i
hire you
so people can get up and running in a
couple of hours and have some level of
proficiency
as a sas business right you charge per
person per month
per seat is perceived what does it cost
perceiving so different tiers
so it's free for individuals up to a few
people got it so if like you're
just like watching us or listening to
this and you want to try it yeah there's
literally no downside
got it uh if you get to the point where
you're at a few editors
15 player mode uh actually you can do
multiplayer mode even when drafts once
it gets to three people
then we charge you uh for um for
basically pro license and that's 15
a month per editor or 12 dollars a month
annually
so it's essentially free it's 150 bucks
a month
yeah like a year a year yes i 150 bucks
a year if you're doing a startup company
and even if you had the most
modest of uh
the most modest of funding 25k from your
aunt
like you can afford yeah that's the 500
bucks a year for the three years to go
on it right and then also if you're an
enterprise company
and you need more sophisticated security
control stuff like that then it's 45
a month per editor so there's a little
bit of price increase there oh yeah so
that's but also the value that you're
getting
is also a lot more as well got it and so
that's six hundred dollars a seat per
year or something like that five six
hundred yeah
which yeah puts you in the creative
cloud kind of
versus adobe kind of space uh i mean
we're still significantly cheaper than
adobe oh yeah what does adobe charge for
the system uh it's
all over the place it depends on which
shop bundle or bucks a month or
something i think you'll probably have
like uh
where you're only a few different apps
yeah so there's like uh
there's like a bundle where it's sort of
a photography bundle for like i think 10
bucks or something yeah
but then there's other sort of um
there's like an educational sku
there's like a business sku there's like
a uh you know skew for
other stuff i heard you before talking
about a little bit about like oh getting
through legal and all this stuff
in is sas at this point as a category
for buyers
cookie cutter enough that you can just
say yeah go to this
url and you can buy 500 seats or do
people who are buying
hundreds of seats need to have a sales
person walk them through everything
and make a specific contract for that
company
this is a great question so um i have a
lot of thoughts on this
uh figma's oriented towards being a
bottom-up model
right and we're trying to make the
business as efficient as possible
explain that to people who don't know in
software as a service basically a
subscription like netskip
like netflix yep what does bottom up
mean yeah so bottom up means that
um people in your organization are able
to adopt it and they're able to spread
it
uh without having to be um to like
necessarily get
a lot of buy-in from those around them
um and you know if you're able to do
that on a
credit card and people are able to be
empowered to actually get their own
tools
uh hopefully they're able to first trial
figma for example for free
and they can go like have a purchasing
conversation with somebody if they need
to
um that's like our ideal scenarios
they're not even being paying for it
and they're like this is actually really
good like let's go bring this into the
organization let's
have this entire team on this and for
what it's worth we also see a lot of
people spread figma when they change
jobs um huh they'll bring it with them
yeah so
you know people are popping between jobs
every few years and they're
they're bringing the tools they like but
anyway so to go back to the
question about bottom up and legal and
sort of what the buy decision looks like
um we're seeing a range of behaviors
right now there's definitely a ton of
companies that
need to spend multiple months or
whatever evaluating software go through
rigorous process
uh especially at larger corporations and
we've got a great amazing sales team
that's like able to partner with them on
that
got it we also what is their main
concern like what are they trying to
accomplish
all that friction something like uh
security is a big one ah
so i wanna make sure that if you're a
cloud provider that you're gonna be
as secure as possible and so that's
something that like for example we've
gone through like the stock 2 process
now
um which is it's basically just a
process to make sure that you're able to
be as secure as possible
even though you're hosted in the cloud
so you have all of my designs i'm
i don't know nike or something and i'm
building a bunch of trusts
i have to trust that yeah your people
are not looking at my designs
they're speaking it or selling it or the
chinese government or the saudi
government hasn't put
a plant into figma like they did at
twitter the saudis actually did this did
you hear that sort of no i did
crazy yeah and so there's sock too and i
was simplifying before it
encompasses a wide variety of controls
everything from like
hiring offer approvals all the way to
like how are your servers running what
are your run books for those oh really
so how do you yeah
do you worry about that i'm curious like
this uh international espionage that you
could actually have like a
a russian saudi or chinese spy working
for you at figma like um
it's nice yeah i i mean i think we're
pretty small-scale and yeah i think um
but that said we're designing the
processes to make sure that we are very
validated uh with every hire we make we
do background checks and everybody
likes making sure that um we're able to
be
feel secure about the data that we're
hosting um but just to go back to the
earlier point because i think it's a
really good one
yeah um one thing that we're we've been
working towards and we're going to
launch soon
is the ability to also self-serve onto
our highest tier which right now you
have to talk to a salesperson for
right and so it's just really important
i think for a lot of companies to be
able to
like have that self-serve motion for
every tier
um because not everyone wants to talk to
a sales person if you do great they're
there
if you don't want to talk to some sales
person like why do you have to i just
want to order my tesla online
like i mean literally i had to buy
a minivan and my biggest fear was buying
the minivan
was going to a dealership and i was like
oh my gosh you don't want to be sold to
you don't want to have to like get the
upsell whatever you're going to be
controlling your destiny
or sit in a room like i'm in part of
some prison experiment where they're
going to
leave and some other person is going to
come in you literally feel like you're
being accused of murder
and they're like sending a good cop in
then a bad cop in and then you're like
okay sign these papers and i'm like what
am i signing do i need a lawyer here
it just feels like horrible yeah that
experience but i think so you're saying
the big companies will even come and
self-serve to buy 500 licenses or
something well
we haven't seen that yet because it's
not shipped but that's my hope is that
we'll start to see more of that
how do you deal with uh and we'll do
this when we get back from the break but
i'm an investor in a company called
capiche.com okay have you heard of that
i have not okay
so what capisce.com is doing
um run by austin peter smith who worked
for me at inside or with me on inside i
should say
um they are tackling the disparity
in how much does this sas software cost
because in our founder secret slack
people the number one sport for startups
is to compare who got the cheapest price
in negotiating with a sas company and
then go yeah
and say my friend got it for this amount
i need that's a really easy free answer
for figma we don't do discounts
yeah and so at all here is capisce and
uh secret society for sas power users
and here they are talking to each other
about
um you can apply for access but you have
to go in and
you have to in order to become a member
of the community you have to give
your pricing but